Hi, Neil from BBC Learning English here. Did you know that we are now offering a new,
weekly, extra episode of 6 Minute English exclusively on our website?
So, go to BBCLearningEnglish.com to find your favourite presenters on your favourite
programme. The extra episodes are only available on our website, BBCLearningEnglish.com.
See you there.
This is a download from BBC Learning English to find out more, visit our website.
6NateEnglish from BBCLearningEnglish.com
Hello, this is 6 Minute English from BBC Learning English. I'm Neil.
And I'm Sam.
Are you feeling well, Sam? No, headache or sore throat?
No, I feel fine, thanks, Neil. Why do you ask?
Well, I've been reading some inspirational stories about the doctors and nurses fighting
COVID. When I was a boy, I always dreamed of becoming a doctor.
Ah, I see. Have you ever been in hospital?
Yes, I have. And I remember the nurses' bedside manner, you know, the kind and caring way
that doctors and nurses treat people who are ill.
Nowadays, more and more of the jobs that humans do are being carried out by machines. But
they doubt that a doctor's bedside manner could easily be replaced by a robot.
In this programme, we'll be discussing whether the revolution in artificial intelligence,
often shortened to AI, could replace human doctors and nurses. We'll be asking, can you imagine
a future without doctors?
In fact, machines are already doing some of the jobs traditionally done by doctors, scanning
people's bodies to detect skin cancer, for example.
Yes, that's true, Sam, and it links to my quiz question, which is about human skin.
It's a well-known fact that skin is the human body's largest organ. But how much skin
does the average adult have? Is it A, 2 square metres, B, 3 square metres, or C, 4 square
metres?
Of course, our skin gets loose as we age, but I can't believe there's 3 square metres
of it. I'll say the answer is A, 2 square metres.
OK, we'll find out if that's correct later. Every year in the UK, over 5 million people
are treated for skin cancer, catch it early and your chances of survival are increased.
Usually, a skin specialist or dermatologist will examine your skin using a handheld microscope.
But in 2017, a team of researchers at Stanford Medical School made an exciting announcement.
Here's Oxford University researcher Daniel Suskind telling BBC World Service Programmed
the Big Idea what the medics at Stanford had invented.
The team of researchers at Stanford last year announced the development of a system that
if you give it a photo of a freckle, it can tell you as accurately as 21 leading dermatologist
whether or not at freckle is cancerous.
The Stanford Medical team had invented an AI system to analyse freckles. Small brown spots
found on people's skin, especially on pale skin.
As it turned out, the AI program was better than doctors telling whether a freckle was
harmless or cancerous connected to some type of cancer.
So it seems that artificial intelligence is already replacing humans when it comes to
detecting cancer and doing a better job of it.
But Daniel Suskind isn't convinced. One reason is that AI systems still need humans to
program them. And as it turns out, knowing exactly how doctors detect illness remains something
of a mystery.
Here's Daniel Suskind again in conversation with BBC World Service Programmed The Big Idea.
If you ask a doc to how is they make a diagnosis, they might be able to point you to particularly
revealing parts of a reference book or give you a few rules of thumb, but ultimately they
struggle. They'd say again, it requires things like creativity and judgment and things are
very difficult to articulate. And so traditionally it's been thought very hard to automate.
If a human being can't explain how they do these special things, where on earth do we begin
in writing instructions for a machine to follow?
Most doctors find it difficult to explain how they make a diagnosis. Their judgment about
what someone's particular sickness is made by examining them.
Diagnosing someone's illness is complicated, but there are some rules of thumb. A rule of thumb
is a practical but approximate way of doing something.
For example, when cooking, a good rule of thumb is two portions of water to one portion
of rice. Exactly. And because identifying sickness is so difficult, Daniel says, where on
earth do we begin writing instructions for a machine? We use phrases like where, how,
or what on earth to show feelings like anger, surprise or disbelief.
I might show surprise by asking Sam, how on earth did you know the answer to that?
Aha, I guess you're talking about your quiz question, Neil. And you didn't be so
surprised. I'm naturally brainy.
Of course you are. In my quiz question, I asked Sam how much skin there is on an adult
human body. And I said it was a two square metres.
Which was the correct answer. With your brains, I think you'd make a good doctor, Sam,
and I'm sure you'd have a good bedside manner too.
Ah, you mean the kind and caring way that doctors and nurses treat their patients.
Okay, let's recap the rest of the vocabulary starting with freckle, a small brown spot
on someone's skin. Freckles are usually harmless, but some skin spots can be cancerous, connected
to cancer. The doctor's diagnosis is a judgment about what someone's particular sickness or
disease is. A rule of thumb is a useful but approximate way of doing or measuring something.
And finally, we use phrases like where on earth as a way to show emotions like anger,
surprise or disbelief.
That's all for this programme, but join us for the next edition of 6 Minute English, when
we'll discuss another trending topic and the related vocabulary.
Why on earth would you miss it? Good bye for now.
Goodbye.